la fête du vélo s'est déroulé pendant
trois jours à montigny le bretonneux
de vendredi à dimanche elle a rassemblé
cyclotouristes et vététistes
la grosse différence et nous on lui
déroule principalement sur les chemins
en forêt le cyclo lui va rouler
principalement sur la route
plusieurs courses étaient proposés pour
cette fête du vélo le 33e rallye du parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse et la 27e rando raid des
renards du manet des parcours allant de
25 à 105 km une initiative du club de
vélo de montigny le bretonneux
il fête ses 40 ans cette année on a la
chance d'être proche de la vallée de
chevreuse et donc d'avoir un terrain de
jeu agréable et riche également en
histoire puisque puisque tout ceci se
déroule autour des châteaux et de lieux
historiques de la région du sud des
yvelines
les parcours se déroule principalement à
travers le parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse les départs
des courses se sont effectuées au
gymnase jules ladoumègue
cette participante s'apprête à pédaler
pendant 25 km le but c'est de rouler
dans notre région qui est magnifique
en fait et on découvre notre région
grâce au vélo
après deux mois d'hôpital pour cet
adhérent le vélo et sa convalescence
c'est agréable de faire du vélo tu sais
moi et puis ça me remet en selle un
petit peu parce que je suis un ancien du
club depuis 28 ans dont j'ai eu un petit
souci de santé
et voilà je reprends ça fait une petite
semaine puis aujourd'hui c'est
merveilleux cette fête du vélo de
montigny le bretonneux a attiré plus de
2000 participants